c'est aussi l'échec des partis
traditionnels oui d'une certaine façon
notamment de la droite puisque la corse
est une terre traditionnellement
attendait les partis traditionnels ont
perdu en 2017 perdre ne cesse de perdre
cette année au niveau national on l'a vu
avec les présidentielles aucun des deux
grands partis traditionnels du paysage
politique français n'ont été présent au
deuxième tour d'élection présidentielle
c'est un séisme dont on connaît
aujourd'hui encore les différentes
répercussions et ce séisme continue les
français on en a assez de la façon de
faire de la politique passée en ont
assez des partis politiques qui
fonctionne à l'ancienne et donc ont
envie de comprendre encore une fois
pourquoi les candidats se présentent aux
élections et demande à ce qu'il y ait
davantage de renouvellement des têtes et
renouvellement des pratiques ils ont
réussi depuis plusieurs années
maintenant à incarner sa lena listes
nationalistes corses et c'est une des
raisons à mon avis majeures pour
lesquelles ils ont lu cette victoire
électorale avec encore il faut pas le
sous-estimer la nécessité de proximité
dans la décision gilles c'est mieux le
leader nationaliste qui sera donc
vraisemblablement reconduit dimanche à
la tête de la région 17 un message très
fort à paris qui après avoir été
silencieux a carrément opté pour
l'hostilité que doit répondre l'état bon
alors il ya toujours le vocabulaire
de l'ordre des leaders nationalistes
c'est paris c'est pas paris c'est c'est
l'état à la rigueur mais le présenter
paris ça nous donne le sentiment qu'on
n'ait pas le même pays la même nation ça
c'est un vrai problème est évidemment
moi je je peux comprendre qu'il ait une
volonté de proximité une volonté de 10,2
de plus grande autonomie dans les
décisions proximité autant je suis
évidemment un farouche opposant à
l'indépendance et d'ailleurs je pense
que leur victoire est liée aussi sur la
fête le fait qu'ils ont modifié leur
leur discours à part un vocabulaire dont
je viens de parler à l'instant le
discours des nationalistes n'est pas un
discours indépendantiste et dans les
différents commentaires qu'on peut voir
les différents réaction des corses il
qu'on prenne la décision ou l'autre cas
la proposition davantage d'autonomie de
proximité de plus de pouvoirs à
proximité mais ils sont contre
l'indépendance est globalement et donc
la difficulté pour eux maintenant dans
les semaines qui viennent c'est de ne
pas apporter justement un discours
indépendantiste qui la leur risque de
leur
porter préjudice parce que ça
démontrerait qu'entre les propos de
campagne et la réalité de ce que serait
peut-être leur arrière pensé à eux les
leaders nationalistes il y aurait un
hiatus les sang et or est une arnaque
aux indépendantistes celles ci sont en
position de force pour demander plus
d'autonomie
forcément quand vous avez des résultats
pareils vous vous êtes dans une
situation politique qui vous permet de
demander un certain nombre de choses aux
interlocuteurs institutionnels dont
l'état et c'est ce qui ne manqueront pas
de faire